how's it going kaley hi john uh
so i'm 21 years old and i've been in a
relationship with a really amazing
guy now for two years the thing is
ever since i was younger i always had
this moral
that i should not have sex until
marriage
and um i've been getting a lot of
backlash
from uh basically all my friends and
anyone who finds this out
saying you know no guy would go two
years without sex like
this and it's been really making me
question the situation so much more
like i you know i just all i know is i
don't want to lose him
that's i'm not really sure what to do
from this point on like i don't know is
it is it fine if it gets to three
four years like how long is really too
long
oh man that's a great question so what
what what put this
this sexual ethic in your head years ago
when you were little
uh um basically every woman in my family
has done this
and not only just that but uh just sort
of like the reasoning behind
it you know knowing like it you i've
seen my friends also like really
the distractions that can come from sex
and um
like how you can really get to know a
person better without that
okay it can make you blind type thing
and i feel like relationships are so
much more than that and
very cool so my initial thought is this
your body is your body and your values
are your values
i don't care what any of your friends
say
your your what you choose to do with you
is your choice
and um if these friends of yours loved
you
and were in your corner they may give
you grief that's what friends do
right they may laugh and carry on but
they're not going to
demean your values whatever they happen
to be
right they may give you their friend
advice which
for all 21 year olds it's about worth
what you pay for right
so you tell me this guy's amazing and
he's been with you for two years
yeah is he pressuring you too how did
those conversations go
sorry is he what is he pressuring you
too or how are those conversations going
yeah so he actually really doesn't
that's the thing i also feel a bad about
it's
like not even one just the backlash but
two i just feel like
at this point like after two years and
also i've actually known him since grade
six we've been best friends all
throughout high school like i feel like
i know him at this point he's such a
good guy and like
it's also just the fact of oh my god
he's such a good guy he never pressures
me he never
asks for it type thing and it's like so
why
aren't i doing it at this point why
aren't you why are you creating
drama where there doesn't appear to be
any you appear to have
some firm values that you've carried for
as long as you can remember and at some
level are generational or legacy
right they're not the norm and that
doesn't make them weird or wrong
that makes them impressive as far as i'm
concerned um
and then you're with somebody who who
cherishes your values
even when they're hard and so it sounds
like things
could not be drawn up better and
there's some sort of discomfort here
where you are
starting to create fire where there is
none
yeah yeah so are you gonna are you gonna
marry this guy
are you all having those conversations
yet yeah
like sort of the thing is right now
we're really young and like
first you know he talks about wanting a
solid career like financial independence
and
uh but he does make remarks like oh when
i marry you this or
lifelong goals we talk a lot about but
the thing is i know i'm not gonna marry
him anytime soon wait what you've known
him okay you are young
fair you're young but you've known this
cat since you were
in sixth grade yeah yeah
so at some point there's some magic
arbitrary number
some age out there right yeah yeah i
don't know
i guess i don't know what what you're
aiming for when it comes to numbers
you're not going to get to know him any
better are you no i don't think so
you're not gonna have any wild like i
gotta get my club in years out
of my life right this doesn't sound like
you
yeah um financial independence is a myth
right that's not like a thing
like he still lives with his parents
though yeah that's probably not going to
work out
right you probably don't want that um
but but all that to say is here's what i
want you to do i want you to
be holy strongly
and firmly committed to whatever your
values are
your body is your body is your body
and your dumb friends in college don't
get a vote
this guy loves you he's known you and
loved you for a long long long long time
and he's all in on your values good for
him
and good for you don't create drama here
where there's none
and man i would really sit down
and think through what spend the rest of
your life with this guy's going to look
like
i don't know what else you're looking
for or what else you think is going to
come up in the next one two
three five years that you're just gonna
wait for i don't
i don't know what you're looking for
it's not like you're gonna get to know
him better it's not like you're going to
um have to learn to trust you've known
this guy forever
right now he does have to move out of
his parents house and so
he could do that sooner rather than
later but
in some situations i tell folks man you
should really take some time
really take some time to get to know
somebody before you marry him other
times
man my friend rachel here she got
married super young was it hard of
course it is
i got married relatively young and it
was super hard
and my friends who got married late
super hard it's just gonna be hard
don't get married just so y'all can
sleep together but also don't put it off
just so you can say we put it off just
so we could say we got married when we
weren't so young
at some point that age is relatively
arbitrary especially if you both have
known each other for a long long time
i love your question it's relatively
simple for me
your body is your body what you choose
is what you choose
and you need to find someone who honors
your values you found that
high five good for you